yeah i was raised by communists i was uh
the editor of the largest magazine of
the new left
um and i left the left what i realized
as
you did eventually um that it's not
about peace
and justice it's a hate america left
these people are they're totalitarians
they want to control every aspect of
your life down to the pronouns
um and that makes them very very
dangerous
i'm dave rubin and joining me is the
original
why i left the left guy as well as the
author of
around 20 books i couldn't even figure
out how many including his most recent
the enemy within
how a totalitarian movement is
destroying america
david horowitz welcome back to the
reuben report thanks for having me dave
i'm glad to have you back on so first
off you've written at least 20 books i
mean do you even know at this point
no i actually don't
but it's like that i've written like
four in the last two years
yeah you you are a prolific writer i
have many of your books on my shelf
uh but let's quickly before we get into
the new book and you've predicted i mean
you really have been
right about so much and i i wonder if
that makes you feel good or
or depressed but before i do anything
else you sort of are the original
why i left the left guy for people that
haven't seen our original interview
we'll link to it down below but you sort
of 30 years
before me made that move uh i suspect
you feel pretty good about it after
coming from a family that was communist
and socialist
and being a lefty and then finally
reagan broke you and here you are
it's hard to feel good about being right
about such terrible things that have
happened to our country
yeah i was raised by communists i was
the editor of the largest magazine of
the new left
um and i left the left what i realized
is
you did eventually um that it's not
about peace and justice
it's a hate america left these people
are
they're totalitarians they want to
control every aspect of your life down
to the pronouns
um and that makes them very very
dangerous
it's a it's a crypto religion as i've
said for a long time
uh they believe in a redemption but they
think the redeemers can be politicians
please there's never a world
that's just because it's made up of
people who are the problem
that's a that's the perception of jenna
the whole
our whole saga is told in genesis in the
bible
had paradise was better than the green
new deal
but there was only one thing you had to
do to stay in paradise and that was not
to want to do
evil and i it's mind-boggling to me
because of the
you have all these live television these
television shows about murders
about how terrible people are if they
just showed you the cruelty to animals
that people are capable of you could
never believe
in a world redeemed by radicals or
any any mortals yeah well i i suspect
that
the mortals on the cover of this book
are are not the mortals that you think
are going to get us
to redemption i mean this is a uh this
is
pretty pretty much all of the bad guys
uh right here
what but that's the favorite part of my
contribution to the book i designed that
cover
there you go you design the cover with
the head shots with the head shots of
some radicals do you
do you believe is it your position that
they all
are equally radical like is is the ill
han omar say aoc
ayanna presley thing or rashida talith
talib thing is that as
is that more radical than say pelosi
schumer biden or is it all just the same
thing at this point
thing in the left and that is that very
there are very few serious people
um we're
living on so much misinformation and
ignorance
so i i think you know people go along
with the crowd
it's survival it's very when i was 35
and left the left i lost every friend
that i had in life
uh and i had to start all over again and
when that happened it seemed impossible
but i've had a good life afterwards so
it's possible but i think most people
are just afraid of losing their friends
that's pretty much
and that's why the left is so vicious in
the way it characterizes its opponents
and uh you know because of that it keeps
everybody in line they don't want to be
called
racist and white supremacist and all
that
um i think we're the sad
reality is that we're in the early
stages of a
fascist state and i use that word
advisedly
if you think of the i just lost a friend
of 70 years ron radasha wrote a
story about it because i questioned the
election results in 2020
i lose a friend of 70 years of when
there's
all these irregularities that are
obvious and when nobody has done an
audit of the election
and when the democrats have challenged
every
republican presidential victory since
2000
2000 2004 of course the trump election
and then if you look what happened on
january 6 this is the great crime
of conservatives first of all
trump's speech basically he said not
basically
literally in so many words he said i
want you to
protest peacefully and patriotically i
want you to
stiffen the spines of weak republicans
who
are afraid to challenge this election
result
and if you fail he said then what you
must do
is go home and primary them
you can imagine a more democratic
peaceful
statement than that okay so those people
went
and for whatever reason some of them got
out of control
and the crime they've been charged
actually charged with
is trespassing there are people who are
still in jail it's now
five months held out bail
for trespassing and what was the
democrats reaction
they called it an armed insurrection
even though there was not a single arm
confiscated zero
zero it was it was actually a fairly
peaceful protest when you think about
everything that happened all summer with
democrat support
they didn't the capital they didn't
destroy a lot of things
uh and the only person who was murdered
or was killed
was a trump supporter and her murderer
is protected by pelosi we still don't
know his name and he's not
they're not going to be any charges and
it was videoed by a journalist who's
showing
that she was completely non-threatening
she was unarmed she's small and she
was threatening nobody when she was
killed
that journalist a hispanic is in jail
for being there and being a journalist
if this isn't fascism i don't know what
it is but it's worse than that
because policy remember she said
republicans are enemies of the state
i remember the the democrats the leftist
the far left and the democratic which is
pretty dominant caucus in the democratic
party
called for the expulsion actually of a
hundred republicans from the house for
questioning the election
josh hawley and ted cruz were singled
out by the democrat leadership
to be removed from the senate because
they questioned an election
when the democrats have done this every
election in recent memory
hillary clinton still has a tweet up
right now about the illegitimate
presidency of donald trump
yeah exactly they never accepted trump
uh
yet this is supposed to be a threat to
our democracy that you raise
and anybody who's looked at the evidence
knows that there was humongous
irregularities of to put a nice term on
it
during the election um but then nancy
pelosi orders
25 000 troops into the capital at a cost
of half a billion dollars
for non-existent non-specified
threat what is that but to send a
message to conservatives
that they're gunning for us then the
head of the military orders a two-month
stand down to conduct a witch-hunt of
so-called extremists
in the military than in the capitol
police than in
homeland security then the justice
department
announces there's there's going to
allocate 89 million dollars
to investigate extremists meaning
conservatives all over the country
it's so reminiscent of the reichstag
fire
hitler was elected in a democracy the
weimar republic
he was elected chancellor he gets into
power and the first thing the nazis do
is they burn down their own capital
called the reichstag
uh blame it on a dutch communist
and uh pass a rep
a the reichstag fire act
to to criminalize dissent which is what
the democrats have been doing ever since
donald trump was elected
criminalized dissent and established the
third reich
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell